our motivations and biases he looks at
the effects of embedding the use of
unnamed sources and the scaling back of
coverage since 2007 on the reliability
of the reporting coming out of Iraq for
the book mr. Jones talked to soldiers
military officials and members of the
media working there the event hosted by
the Library of Virginia in Richmond is
45 minutes thanks a lot thanks for being
here I'm glad to see some students in
the audience with uniforms on I'm
expecting some tough questions from you
guys we thought since this is a book
about the media and really the
multimedia we'd start with a very brief
video which is you can you can watch
later if you if you see this and just
see glimpses you want to see it again go
to the books website which is really
easy
ww red white or yellow comm and you can
go on there and you can check out the
video and if you want to order another
sign book you can do that too so what
we're going to do is go right into the
video
I'm going to sit down and get back up
and do my philip delivered remarks
red white or yellow the median military
at war in Iraq is a story of conflict
controversy politics courage boredom
deadlines celebrities blogs internet
propaganda TV network personalities such
as Paris Hilton and Nicole Smith Geraldo
Rivera Oliver North and Bill O'Reilly
but ultimately it's a story about the
role the good reporting place and
keeping our country and its leaders
honest why did the American media by and
large fall on its face and fail in 2002
and 2003 to properly question and report
the flaws in President Bush's plan to
invade Iraq was the coverage skewed by
the media's own post 9/11 patriotic
impulses and once the war began how did
Donald Rumsfeld's Pentagon control
machine stifle vigorous questioning from
reporters at US Central Command and did
the United States try to communicate its
message to the Arab world through al
Jazeera or did America right off the
Islamic audience these are just some of
the questions that I posed when I began
investigating the difficult story of the
media and military in Iraq a story that
sadly is still unfolding today but a
story which is not going to go away it's
one that's at the center of this fall's
presidential campaign
America's media coverage of Iraq is
eerily reminiscent of an earlier war the
spanish-american War when a media mogul
named William Randolph Hearst uses vast
newspaper Empire to browbeat another
president into manufacturing the pretext
for invading a troublesome country Cuba
in Iraq though one might argue that the
roles were reversed that is the
president and his skilled political
advisor Karl Rove and shadowy Vice
President Dick Cheney led Bush to spend
his considerable political power
to make invading Iraq seem like the
right thing to do given the alleged
threat from weapons of mass destruction
remember them WMDs in Iraq a dictator is
building and hiding weapons that could
enable him to dominate the Middle East
and intimidate the civilized world and
we will not allow it
of course we now know that the WMDs were
not the immediate threat they were made
out to be and at the New York Times in
to a lesser degree in The Washington
Post the two most prominent newspapers
became unwitting accomplices in the
selling of this war my book is called
red white or yellow because in my view
the covers by fox and others repeated
the type of journalism created by Hearst
and his ilk that is sensationalistic
opinionated commercially driven and
fueled by a political agenda yellow
journalism after my initial interviews
with top journalists such as cnn's jamie
mcintyre and rick atkinson of the
Washington Post and Jim Lehrer of PBS it
became evident to me that I could not
avoid going to Iraq to better understand
this story I worked at a newspaper then
which like so many papers was going
through budget cuts and pulling back on
any national or international coverage
so in the summer of 2007 I took my
two-week summer vacation and paid my own
way to Kuwait and then Iraq I embedded
with the Marine Corps Public Affairs
Office at Camp Fallujah and spent
countless hours watching them deal with
media inquiries from around the world
and waging a battle against some of the
craftiest propagandists in the world
that is al Qaeda I watched these Marines
try to avoid being used by Al Qaeda and
wage a smarter battle and what's known
as information or perception warfare
when the u.s. issues a press release
every time a bomb goes off marine major
Jeff Poole argues this just gives fodder
for the enemy propaganda s-- who may be
sitting at a coffee shop in London and
just monitoring the intern
and allows them to issue a jihad
inspired press release about the cross
waving Crusaders suffering yet another
defeat ultimately red white or yellow is
a book about a very moving target that
is the first war where everything is
reported in real time and where images
such as those from Abu Ghraib may be
taken on soldiers cell phones it is a
book about America's first war of the
21st century and provides a number of
vital lessons for politicians generals
and average citizens alike and what to
watch out for when one is reading
dispatches from the front or in the case
of bloggers from the rear of the action
and this is a book about the courage of
soldiers Marines Airmen and sailors
alike who in the face of public
indifference to a war that's become
increasingly unpopular continue to do
their jobs and to serve their country
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's really great to return to the
library of Virginia which is truly one
of the treasures in Richmond and a place
that encourages Virginia based writers
such as myself and I think Mary Beth
MacIntyre is not here today but her
staff thank Dan for the kind
introduction and everybody here at the
Library of Virginia foundation for
inviting me to be part of this luncheon
series and mostly I thank you all for
being here today it's really a privilege
to be here to discuss my book and I look
forward to any questions you might have
and I'm really mean that since this is a
book about reporting and what goes into
it I thought I would have a little bit
of fun by interviewing myself
question one so chip why did you decide
to write a book about such a huge
controversial subject and I have a
follow-up were you out of your mind
let's start with the second part of the
question was I out of my mind indeed I
think I was going through some sort of
psychic turmoil when shortly after the
start of 2007 I accepted the challenge
which came from my editor Chris Evans at
Stackpole books in Pennsylvania I was
looking to follow up my first book about
the Marine Corps basic school class of
67 boys of 67 which is still out in
paperback by the way when another book
idea fell through I was open to
accepting a challenge which if I'd spent
too much time thinking about its scope
and his controversy I might well have
said nah no thanks now some of you here
might remember back in the mid to late
1990s when I reported for the Richmond
times-dispatch
a long-running saga that also had its
share of controversy and heat that is
the federal investigation in lawsuits
against Philip Morris USA and the entire
tobacco industry along with my old
times-dispatch colleague Peter Harden we
were privileged to help expose some of
the cigarette makers many sins of
commission and omission with nicotine
campaign
marketing to youth and the like but this
assignment to write a book about Iraq
and the media far surpassed the scope of
anything I tackled with the Marlboro Man
the underlying premise in question was
basically this was it true what some
conservative critics were saying over
and over in 2006 that the liberal media
was distorting news coverage of the war
and if so why
we're news outlets trying to make up for
the mistakes they'd made in 2003 after
they essentially were used by the Bush
administration to get the country
excited about invading Iraq and toppling
Saddam Hussein was their quote good news
from Iraq such as building schools and
holding elections that was not reported
because the left-leaning media was so
intent on getting back at Bush and
Cheney and Rumsfeld after the search for
weapons of mass destruction turned up
empty and after so much rhetoric had
driven us all into a kind of war frenzy
it turned out to be nothing but cleverly
spun propaganda booth that is a long
question and worse for a writer such as
myself it's also a run-on sentence but I
wanted to pose it because it describes
essentially the early thrust of my book
why I went into it why I started looking
at these questions to describe the whole
problem I used a variety of journalistic
techniques interviews accounts from news
reports and even as I said in the video
my own experiences during a brief in bed
with the Marines in mid-2007 by the way
in case you're wondering about the title
red white or yellow as mentioned on the
video it's a play on words that refers
both to the red white and blue patriotic
reaction of the media in 2003 remember
the flags on the lapels of the news
anchors and the various slogans and the
breathless
unapologetically Pro administration tone
remember how the networks use the
language created by the administration
that editorialize the coverage calling
it operate Operation Iraqi Freedom
rather than simply war in Iraq
remember the upbeat martial music that
was played before and after commercial
breaks the key here is I try to help you
the reader remember what might have
gotten lost in the fog of this long long
war perhaps next time around if god
forbid we were called to arms again we
might view the whole thing in a more
detached manner remembering Yeats
admonishment to cast a cold eye on life
and death
and with apologies to Yeats perhaps we
could paraphrase him and say cast a cold
eye on the government and on the media
the yellow in the title refers to the
history of yellow journalism practiced
by that notorious media Baron of the
late 19th century William Randolph
Hearst whom for your students here Orson
Welles immortalized in Citizen Kane
Hearst you'll recall is credited or
blamed as the case may be for nearly
single-handedly driving America into war
with Spain over Cuba in 1898 you'll note
the historical parallel with Hearst
modern-day counterpart media Baron
Rupert Murdoch owner of multiple
newspapers and networks around the globe
now including the Wall Street Journal
and of course Fox TV next question so is
this a history book not really but I
tried to include relevant slices of
history including the early days of
combat correspondence which most
historians agree date back to 1854
during the Crimean War when William
Howard Russell of The Times of London
marked the beginning of an organized
effort to report a war to the civilian
population at home using the services of
a civilian reporter writes Philip
Knightley in his seminal work on combat
reporting and a book I highly recommend
you're interested in the top
the first casualty Russell and his
gripping account of the British light
brigade battling the Russians wrote
through the clouds of smoke we could see
their Sabres flashing until quote not a
British soldier except the dead and
dying was left in front of the muscovite
guns now you might recall from English
class Tennyson's poem the charge of the
Light Brigade with its stirring opening
lines half a league half a league half a
league onward all in the valley of death
rode the six hundred in red white or
yellow I tapped many historical and
contemporary sources to create what I
hope is a compelling portraits portrait
of today's correspondents who covered
valleys of death surrounded by crumbling
tenement apartments in Baghdad or stores
in the bombed out city of Fallujah
furthermore in what I think of as a post
modernist sort of twist in this complex
narrative of war and reporting in an age
of instant communication this is also a
story of people and institutions at war
with themselves some of the journalists
in the audience might build appreciate
that so I'll repeat that it's a story of
people and institutions at war with
themselves next question okay what do
you mean by that anytime someone uses
the word postmodern you got to ask them
a question about it
well as you'll see in the opening
chapter this was a war whose coverage
was shaped and then diminished by the
fairly precipitous decline of the
newspaper industry and the resulting
cutbacks and staff and in commitments to
covering the war which after all is
expensive in time money and personnel as
a result when I arrived in Baghdad last
year there was basically a skeleton crew
of people covering the combat I was one
of fewer than 40 journalists actually
embedded with the military this does not
include the news bureaus of CNN Poe's
New York Times and Baghdad those people
are not technically embedded with the
military which means you
have orders with the Department of
Defense and you if you read the book
you'll get a detailed account of what it
means to be embedded but in terms of
embed reporters I think there was about
39 at the time and where I was in Anbar
province which is the size of the entire
state of North Carolina in western Iraq
there were four embedded reporters I was
one of them now I don't think there's
any doubt that as a result of the
newspapers demise and reduce presence of
the broadcast and cable news networks
that you and you and you and all of you
as readers or viewers receive less and
less news at a time when the war needed
more and more explanation and I should
add this applies to the continuing
military presence in Afghanistan though
I had to limit my research to Iraq Jo
climb a time correspondent told me when
I met him last summer that he traveled
to Baghdad because quote I don't think
we're taking the war seriously enough I
think all publications and networks are
seeing the same kind of marketing
surveys showing Americans had grown
weary of the war quote advertisers don't
want to have their ads on the pages next
to it coupled with that newspapers began
to promote local coverage in order to
increase penetration of their product
and make new pitches to advertisers as a
result of this coverage gap I heard from
the rank of private to general from
service people who felt angry bitter and
disconnected from a country that was
seemingly shrugging its collective
shoulders at their sacrifices this
disconnect between the military and the
nation's messengers that is the media is
part of the narrative of America's first
war of the 21st century on the media
side I report about the doubts and the
frustrations of some fine reporters who
were and still are committed to covering
Iraq even when their bylines are knocked
off the front page to leave room for
some County Supervisors
or perhaps the latest on American Idol
or Paris Hilton there whoever's
celebrity of the day I also explore how
the war has changed the nature of the
media itself including the rise of
bloggers who tried to fill some of the
void left by mainstream media finally
red white or yellow is about the dangers
of mixing mass marketing and the news as
the recent flap at MSNBC / Keith Oberman
and Chris Matthews shows Fox's
flag-waving formula for success has
permanently altered the landscape for
much of TV news as one New York Times
report put it recently quote the success
of Fox News Channel in the past decade
along with the growth of political blogs
has convinced many media companies that
provocative commentary attracts viewers
and lures web browsers more than
straight news delivered dispassionately
there's one overarching cautionary theme
in red white or yellow it's the
importance of maintaining the separation
between the news and advertising sides
sides of the news business or what we
used to call separation of church and
state the church was the place for us
the newshounds free of interference from
the other side of the business state
otherwise known as the bean counters was
where advertising was peddled and papers
were sold
now obviously papers and networks alike
have to sell ads to pay their bills and
to pay reporters like me or editors but
there has been a disturbing trend that
many in the public only faintly grasp of
marketers and others from outside the
newsroom influencing or even dictating
but stories are covered how they're
covered and even pulling strings to have
stories censor and watered down or worse
dumbed down when this happens in my in
my opinion the paper or the network or
the editor has perhaps
the name of survival given up the core
values of our profession if you think
this is overstating the case consider
what happened to Phil Donahue in the
early days of the war he was fired by
MSNBC he was told
according to editor & Publisher quote he
could not feature war dissenters on his
MSNBC talk show and always had to have
quote to conservatives for every liberal
a leaked NBC memo explained that Donahue
presented quote a difficult public face
in a time of war at the same time our
competitors are waving the flag at every
opportunity you'll see in my book other
examples of less than stellar behavior
by some TV correspondents including
those covering the war from Qatar and
plenty of poor behavior on the part of
the government as well now as I stepped
down from my soapbox talking about
journalism and its standards let me ask
a question some of the more skeptical
among you might be thinking especially
the younger among you so what's the
point of even thinking about this stuff
when we the better off watching
SportsCenter well I like ESPN as much as
the next fan especially when Monday
night basketball is on and my beloved
Kansas Jayhawks are playing but I hope
this book gives you some food for
thought at least during the commercials
and I would contend that for you
readers viewers and consumers of
increasing amounts of information
perhaps an overload of information in
this 24/7 news cycle age it's worth
stepping back and analyzing the impact
of the slick and sophisticated message
making of our brave new media history is
always a good place to start and I
mentioned in the book that during the
Nuremberg trials after World War two one
Nazi officer described the work of
Hitler's propaganda chief Joseph
Goebbels
this way quote the conquest of the
masses was possible only by spreading
propaganda to prepare the ground
psychologically for political action and
pterri aggression unquote and never
forget that Hitler's propaganda chief
gurbles was well-versed in the
techniques of American mass advertising
if you think we as a human race have
somehow completely evolved from the
brute forces of domination and demeaning
others that fed into the hatred of Nazi
Germany and the Holocaust consider our
own media environment today and the
emotionally charged and often angry
commentary and stereotypes that have
been employed whether consciously or
subliminally in the current presidential
race so I hope red white or yellow
allows each reader to reflect back in
Iraq in a new way and perhaps even on
the election in a new way and consider
how the keepers of the news were so
easily outfoxed by the government I've
noticed in the presidential race for
example how easy it is to make the media
the issue and the scapegoat which of
course is a charge that usually can
either be proved nor disproved it's a
way I believe that political hacks
managed to take our eyes off the
important questions of the day and what
should be happening which is to make
leaders more accountable and honest and
forward-thinking again I think it's
important for people like you readers
and thinkers to exercise their rights
and duties as citizens to question
authority and that includes questioning
the media
write them letters protest stupid
stories protest dumbing down the
newspaper post things on YouTube start
blogs whatever it takes these are the
kinds of questions of questions I hope
my book will raise but only you can find
the answers that work for you and I'm
quite sure you you likely won't agree
with everything I've said here today or
everything I write in the book and
observe about the coverage which is fine
my goal is to inspire civil debate not
win an argument
and speaking of arguments one of my
favorite examples of a reporter cutting
through the fog of disinformation occurs
when a clever reporter Jamie McIntyre of
CNN the senior defense correspondent the
Pentagon managed to outmaneuver Donald
Rumsfeld by using the Pentagon's own
dictionary of terms over the word
guerrilla warfare that was after months
of denial by Rumsfeld and the President
and Vice President and others in the
administration that Iraq was embroiled
in a guerrilla or civil war or an
insurgency so I hope you'll find some
food for thought about the importance
also of naming things the importance of
naming things and the relationship
between language and truth George
Orwell's essay politics in the English
language is one of my guide posts in
1946 just after the end of World War two
he warned quote in our time political
speech and writing are largely the
defense of the indefensible and I would
invite you to reread or well as a kind
of antidote to every single talking head
and candidate and pundit and shrill
campaign commercial and after you do ask
this question have you just watched
another defense of the indefensible and
if you watch Jon Stewart or Stephen
Colbert as I like to do you'll realize
that political discourse has become so
bloated and so obviously deceptive that
someone has to poke a pin in it and
laugh or otherwise we won't be able to
maintain our sanity now the stuff
despite my many criticisms the
politicians the government and some in
the media red white or yellow really is
not a polemic it's it's more of a story
within a story and I hope you'll enjoy
the stories that are told there and the
people you'll meet it's filled with
colorful characters and provocative
questions including many about the
implications of this war for the
military of the future
I raised many questions in this book I
don't claim to have all the answers with
an unfolding story like this not even
Bob Woodward has all the answers though
I admire the ones he's
come up with lately in my own way I've
tried to capture the ambivalent mood
that I found among troops waiting for
planes to take them into battle
including many military contractors I
meant along the way and also what I
found among the Marines at Camp Fallujah
in a Rox most western province Anbar in
particular I try to share some of the
thoughts and frustrations and lessons
offered by one particularly smart vocal
marine public affairs officer major Jeff
Poole who probably has spent more time
trying to coordinate coverage or answer
questions from top reporters in Iraq and
Afghanistan that any other active duty
officer in the US military
pool was especially passionate about the
importance of the military learning to
be smarter and how it worked with and
not against the media and also in
becoming smarter and how it responded to
various unfounded reports they quickly
could turn into propaganda fodder for
al-qaeda as I alluded to in the video
especially on that great equalizer of
all media today the Internet I hope to
convey the humanity the fal ability and
even some of the dark humor of the
serious business about writing about men
and women fighting and dying for their
country I wanted to know what motivated
reporters to cover war in the first
place and ask questions that maybe you
as a reader might ask especially why
anyone chooses to leave the safe
confines of a newsroom for the unsafe
and uncomfortable back of a truck or a
Humvee or helicopter facing a very
clever and well-armed opponent in a very
hot and war ravaged land you'll meet
Rick Atkinson of the Washington Post a
friend of mine from way back who spent
the invasion with a hard-charging
general who headed the 101st Army
Airborne Atkinson's portrait of David
Petraeus shows a general who had doubts
right off the bat constantly asking tell
me how this ends and yet Petraeus who
just
yesterday as the military commander in
Iraq returned to lead a
counterinsurgency campaign that in the
face of a major foreign policy defeat
may just allow America to get out of
Iraq with his head held high and perhaps
someone intact when I was in Iraq there
was absolutely no certainty at all about
the outcome as major Poole told me the
attitude among many reporters was that
the O'War appeared to be lost so quote
now the question is how can we lose
gracefully how can we lose less was that
media bias or was that a logical
question given the seeming lack of a
coherent strategy you be the judge
beyond the issues I tried to explain why
and how reporters cover tough stories in
a chapter called as he lay dying I
interviewed the New York Times young
correspondent Damian cave about a very
tough story he covered along with combat
photographer Bob Nichols Berg in the
early days of the surge I balanced that
interview with an account of the
grieving family shocked to see their
loved one in a photo in the New York
Times on the front page who then
suffered through having his funeral
turned into a media circus and you'll
meet a familiar name and face from the
Richmond times-dispatch
Rex Bowman Roenick correspondent and
you'll perhaps learn a little bit more
about him and how why he went to the
front of the line to go to Iraq as soon
as he saw the planes hitting the Twin
Towers in New York City
Bowman's role model was the great world
war two correspondent Ernie Pyle who he
said quote covered not war but men at
war that was the template I had Rex also
told me something that rang true with my
own experience as a reporter asked about
alleged bias he said of his own thoughts
at the time when he was going into Iraq
quote I didn't know if I was right or
wrong wise or foolish
I have the same attitude about abortion
and the death penalty I can write with
indifference and I don't know who's
right or wrong he noted his on-the-job
training covering long boring meetings
and trials and observed it's very easy
to be disinterested when you cover
Planning Commission's I could I could
relate to that and he said he can he
compared his role as a reporter to that
of a professional mediator who has asked
he was able to see multiple sides of an
issue with equanimity he said why can't
we accept the journalists can be
even-handed that's the way I went into
the war I did not know who was right or
wrong did not care if they were right or
wrong all I knew is it was a story to be
covered and finally another quote that
seemed to frame a lot a lot of these big
questions came from Jim Lehrer of PBS a
former marine himself and when I asked
him about the criticisms from 2005 and
2006 that the media had ignored quote
positive news on the war Lera told me
well I can't imagine someone saying
there's not enough good news from war
that's absurd
war is about killing people and more
reporting is about why they do it and
how they do it
so on that sobering note I thank you for
your attention and I invite your
questions unfortunately I don't have a
flak jacket or helmet with me thank you
very much
[Applause]
that is sensationalistic and you native
commercially-driven
this is perhaps beyond the scope of your
book but as a person old enough to go on
through five or six Wars now and knowing
having my own recollection about at
least living in California that Vietnam
was as ill-advised as Iraq has the media
learned anything from those Wars and how
it's been used by administrations to
present administration's policies rather
than something more balanced because it
seems to me that's always that's a very
good point
to try to answer the question straight
up has the media learned anything I
would I would I guess my response would
be yes some and the media have I mean
that the see what I would think of as
the serious journalists the people that
go to panel discussions at Northwestern
their number of books that I allude to
in and grab some discussion about this
we're back in 2004 2005 some of the top
of broadcast and print reporters were
actually engaged in some discussion with
the basically top military people who
were operating under this terrible
constraint you know the I think they
call it call it Rumsfeld 5,000 miles
screwdriver they were in Baghdad trying
to trying to answer questions the roll
them public affairs military people is
to provide a conduit you know that's
their role that they believe in that
that's part of the reason why they're
fighting the First Amendment the problem
was even as the media struggle to figure
out why we weren't getting
more straight answers from the top
military people the people in Baghdad
who were trying to give the answers
we're really looking over the shoulder
back at Washington and in fact I there
there's a quote in the book from a very
fine of Vietnam era correspondent a
woman I can't think of her name right
now but she made a very good point at
one of the panel discussions I was at
was that the difference of a
correspondent to then was that she could
file her story send it in and it would
go in the paper after being edited but
she wouldn't be on a cell phone with an
editor saying well we're being told by
the White House of the Pentagon that
what you're writing isn't true or
whatever point is the 24/7 and global
communications we have has altered the
actual dynamic of reporting and the
truth of the matter is I think the media
is struggles with that because a lot of
this war when you're in Baghdad you were
really writing for an audience in
Washington
unlike even the Vietnam War where the
battle reports would have just been
fairly straightforward at least in the
you know early to middle days of the war
so I don't know if that answers your
question but you know I think and one of
the premises of book is that friction is
inevitable and and the government has to
struggle with how it how much
information it releases and I don't know
sort of a historical side note I'll
mention my next book is gonna be a
smaller book about a documentary
filmmaker marine named Norman hatch who
was the only marine on Tarawa to film
the bloody battle there and he shared
with me recently what happened when his
footage went back to Washington and
Franklin Roosevelt saw it Roosevelt
didn't think at the time that they
should wasn't sure that they should
release the battle footage so he untold
that that Roosevelt conferred with the
time-life correspondent whose name was
Robert Sherrod very famous war
correspondent Bob sherrod my father
happened to know him
and Bob Sharat called him down from
Washington asking the question it said
absolutely mr. president we need to
release this information because at the
time America didn't realize what a long
long war we were going to be in with
Japan so I say that because that was 70
years ago and these questions about
access and you know do we release
certain things and not others have
always been there the difference is the
instantaneous nature that we showed the
picture of Abu Ghraib up there cell
phones
I mean I'm told right now that inside
the Pentagon there's a debate over
whether cellphones have to be banned for
combat troops why because there's been
cases I'm told this is all anecdotal but
cases where when American so dead
American soldiers having captured the
enemy obviously knows how to look at a
cell phone and then that gives you
intelligence about what a compound looks
like or who knows be used in lots of
ways so all these issues you know cell
phones the internet you know that was
the thing I was amazed that help me
going there to see just how plugged in
the military is and you'll see at the
beginning of the book how disappointed
the military was that I was around that
everyone was focused on Paris Hilton and
the war was gone so I don't think you
know if I hadn't have spent a little
time over there I wouldn't have real I
wouldn't get that emotional sense of
that disconnect I think is probably
still there hi I was wondering why
things been under reported that she had
leadership in Iraq rise to Iran I
understand that they all had Malik I
spent time there in his exile and all
the leaders have ties to Iran MacIntyre
and while it was reported I don't think
was widely reported EVs
they came Evon already that I couldn't
write Minister a lot probably the better
understand ounces named Mohammed I
worked at a match at Yahoo visited Iraq
and gave an anti us speech like your
comments thank you
well there's a there's an expression in
the military you know that's outside my
lane or above my paygrade
I I mean I can tell you you know that I
have read accounts of Prime Minister
Maliki being having ties tore through
Iran I mean I think that that's
generally been reported now what you're
saying is and I respect your opinion on
this is that maybe it's been
underreported you know you never know I
mean you all are obviously readers or
you wouldn't be here probably this
audience is more aware of it and say you
know somebody looked like me ooh I hear
more the interesting discussions you
hear around Richmond is in the locker
room at the YMCA you know and you'll
just hear somebody blasting away on
anything so I guess I guess the issue
there is it does go back to something I
do raised in the book it's the
importance of following foreign affairs
you know in the paper and also on the
news now you can make a real effort and
watch news hour and Charlie Rose and
probably a lot of you do and I think
that's the only way to do it but I think
what you're saying is correct in a sense
that you know I know it's been reported
I don't know the extent whether you know
it's satisfactory or not for a variety
of personal reasons early in this war I
I fell into following al-jazeera and
their coverage of the war and I'm
curious that in framing of your book or
how you proceeded or just as a
journalist do you frequently consult I
guess really alternative views of what
you're reporting and Al Jazeera would be
a good example of the Iraq war I think
anyway it would be to be honest I had
not watched or seen much of Al Jazeera I
mean I was like most people it was like
I would just sort of you know taken the
administration line that it was
basically a terrorist platform
it wasn't until you'll see a chapter in
the book where I interview a former
Marine captain Josh rushing who I think
there's a documentary called control
room which I have I have not actually
seen that but okay good that's cool yeah
well josh is a former Marine that I
interviewed up in Washington
I went to Al Jazeera English which is up
there in DC heavily guarded and I wanted
to include in my book for balance
you know his point of view which he also
expressed in a book that he published
that first of all it was a mistake to
make a lowly marine captain the voice I
have friends here or in public relations
that they can imagine this the cap it'd
be like if you took an intern said okay
you go out and talk to a hundred million
people in the arab viewing audience
that's what happened to Josh why is
basically because of prejudice you know
I mean it was sort of like why would we
want to talk to those people
now there were political undertones to
that and and that's where there's a lot
of shades of gray here you know a lot of
the coverage was skewed by the anger
over 9/11 and the residual you know want
to get back at people kinds of attitudes
even among the reporters and they don't
deny that now but to answer your
question I you know in looking and
researching this book some of the
alternative places I look we're on the
blogosphere you can look at you can look
at bill Rowe Geo's blog which I wrote a
chapter where I interviewed him it's
called the third rail I believe and
there's small Wars Journal there's a lot
of alternative sources about military
information but al Jazeera is something
I'm more or less just discussed in
general it's not I don't I can't watch
it I think my neighbor watches it she's
from Jordan I should go over and like
sit around with her sometime
yeah exactly
oh yeah yeah I know it's just it's just
that the folks who put that al-jazeera
together were in fact a journalist from
BBC they got cut and in a situation much
like you described was going on in the
United States right and they were just
attempting to be good journalists and
they were slandered by the same forces
you're talking about yeah I agree in and
I learned I learned from Josh rushing
just by reading this book and talking to
him that there was no there was not one
point of view among all those people but
but the one thing they did share of the
journalists at al-jazeera the one thing
they did share that was different in the
coverage they provided was what happened
to the civilian population when are
supposed you know surgical strikes
arrived you know that's that's what and
that created a real problem obviously
for Donald Rumsfeld and everybody in the
Pentagon because you know it's it's one
thing to talk about
you know shock and awe and then it's
another thing to see you know the the
babies and women and men died so that
was really the Al Jazeera question and
and I I don't think that they've really
they being you know the government and
the DoD I don't know that they've
actually gotten their hands around that
problem but it's something that really
ought to be addressed and and Josh
Rushing's point was you know what Israel
the Israeli it's going aljazeera I know
that was an amazing point why aren't we
there at least making our point make our
pitch
after the attacks on 9/11 what would
have been the proper military response
from a journalist point of view the
proper military response after the
attacks on 9/11
yes well again yeah
I would have to put that in the internet
a journalist as like Rex Bowman said the
proper response is to cover the story if
we had not gone into Iraq well we went
into Afghanistan if we if we had not
gone there the proper response would
have been to say well why not I think
the proper response looking back and
you'll see in the book I don't know if
you remember that the apologies of the
New York Times The Washington Post I
don't know if you remember Bill Moyers
did a fine documentary on the issue
I think the improper response is to not
be conscientious and thorough enough in
your coverage the proper response for a
journalist for a reporter is to cover
the story you know but there are layers
of coverage you know there's the rex
bowman who goes in as a correspondent or
the Rick Atkinson who goes with David
Petraeus and tries to provide the big
picture but then there's the
investigative reporters in Washington
and New York and their role which has
been and this isn't my argument the book
has been diminished by all these
cutbacks so the proper response of the
media companies is to quit cutting staff
the proper response of the media
companies is to hire new journalists I
would argue there's a whole lost
generation of writers I'm looking at a
couple of them here in the audience who
are not writing at major newspapers
right now because of the cutbacks and
people in their late 20s and 30s and
who's who's going to lose in the long
run you all so that's a long-winded way
of saying the proper response is to
cover the story journalist Charles Jones
is the author of boys of 67 from Vietnam
to Iraq the extraordinary story of a few
good men which was named the top
biography of 2006 by the military
Society of America he embedded with the
Marines in Iraq during the summer of
2007 for more information about
journalist Charles Jones author of red
white or yellow